My name is Benjamin
Kokasa, a student of Egalai Media form
academy. My first question is you said
um when Jesus Christ died
um rising up he told the people that he
is going to send his father is going to
send a comforter to them. But to what I
believe or what I learned from church is
that he was going to send the Holy
Spirit down onto them. So I just want to
know from you that what do you people
believe it is? The brothers asked the
question that when Jesus Christ peace be
upon him says that I will send you a
comforter when he goes he's talking
about the Holy Spirit. That's what the
church says. What is my view? Brother I
gave the reply to this in my talk. It's
mentioned in the gospel of John chapter
number 14 verse number 16. Jesus Christ
peace be upon him says that I will pray
to my father to send you a comforter who
will abide with you forever. Gospel of
John chapter number 15:26 says but when
the comforter comes who I will send from
my father he will testify me. Gospel of
John chapter number 16 verse number 7
says nevertheless I tell you the truth.
It is expedient for you that I go away
for if I go not away the comforter shall
not come. The criteria for the comforter
to come is that Jesus Christ peace be
upon him should go. Only after he goes
will he send the comforter. If you say
the comforter was the Holy Spirit, we
already know from the Bible that the
Holy Spirit was there before Jesus
Christ peace be upon him came onto this
earth before he was born. The Holy
Spirit was there in the womb of
Elizabeth. The Holy Spirit was also
there when Jesus Christ peace be upon
him was being baptized. So this prophecy
cannot refer to the Holy Spirit. It
refers to no one but the last and final
messenger, Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him.